and that's sort of what that's where the
West is powerful I would say like we
have a really well developed mythology
of the exploratory hero but where we're
not so well developed is the second part
because in the second part of the
classic hero story you're supposed to
come back and communicate about what you
found and so there's a individual
exploration element and then there's a
communicate and update the culture
element and both of those are equally
important and it's something that we
don't do well we don't have much respect
for tradition in the West and it's a
really really big problem because the
ethical responsibility of a human being
is to take the dead culture so that's
the dead father or the dead God and to
reveal Phi it with attention and
communication and you fail to do that
and everything disappears and we we are
failing to do that we're leaving it all
behind instead it's not a good idea you
know if the old gods die as nietzsche
said they had new gods swoop in very
rapidly and if you think the old god was
bad you wait till the new gods get ahold
of you so while we saw what happened in
the 20th century right with all the
ideologies that sprang up in the absence
of classical religious belief it's like
okay or you're not so thrilled with
Catholicism if you think about that is
you know the fundamental tradition of
the West you know with the witch
burnings and the Inquisition and all
about it's like yeah yeah well get a
load of the Nazis and then see what you
think so for the communists for that
matter it's like from bad to worse in an
unimaginable way you know so and it's
partly because those archaic systems
those archaic religious systems they
weren't ideologies there are a whole
different class of things and we don't
understand them very well and it's not
good because you cannot live without
understanding them you don't know who
you are and then you fall prey to weird
mental diseases like nihilism that's
that's one another one is ideological
possession so you become a totalitarian
or a Nautilus and that's a bad outcome
and you might think well what's the
alternative
well you know what happens in Pinocchio
right you watch Pinocchio okay I often
show Pinocchio to this class but I don't
know
to do that this year but anyway
Pinocchio he's a puppet marionette
someone else is pulling his strings
has it wasn't head he's not very bright
he hasn't banged around the world at all
he's not a good father the old Geppetto
who really would rather that he was a
real boy right a real person so he's the
kind of father that wants to produce an
individual and not a slave so and that's
why you know in his workshop it's all
friendly and there's a nice fire he's
making toys and there's lots of music
it's like go Geppetto he's a good guy so
it makes this little puppet and he sends
them all the neuroses go be a real boy
well
Pinocchio runs into a whole class of
different obstacles one is evil right
that's the that's the coachman and the
Italian stereotype guy who makes him a
dancing puppet celebrity which I think
it's pretty funny I mean that's really
prescient you know because you might
think well what's the goal of your
typical boneheaded you know
mid-adolescence in North America it's
like onions celebrity well that's
exactly what Pinocchio goes from first
and that doesn't work out so well
because he ends up the slaves and then
the next thing that happens is he
capitalizes on the fact that he's
vulnerable and pretend to be sick and
goes off for a vacation under the
direction of the coachman who's
basically Satan in disguise then he goes
out to Treasure Island Pleasure Island
and meets all the delinquents who are
just like Nazis and it turns out that in
fact the whole ploy is to enslave
everyone to deprive them of their voice
that's the donkey braying and to make
them into slave pretty damn horrifying
and that was that movie came out about
the same time that the Nazis were really
you know grasping power in Central
Europe like they got it exactly right
here's what's really going on behind the
scenes so and then what happens while
Pinocchio turns half way into a braying
donkey because you know he's gone off
the path and in order to get back on it
he tries to go home but it's too late
he's grown up you can't go home he's not
a kid anymore goes home and dad isn't
there surprise surprise because once you
grow up and you go home dad isn't there
it's just another human being so then
what happens well then he has to go into
the ocean
particularly weird right it's like there
is half donkey he's a puppet the dub
comes down and drops him a message from
God like the Holy Spirit descending
except it's actually from the Blue Fairy
weirdly enough and the message says you
have to go to the deepest part of the
ocean and rescue your father but yeah
that is what you have to do if you don't
want to be a bloody puppet donkey you
have to go down into the depths and find
your dead father and you have to
revivify him and that's what happens so
Pinocchio goes way down there to the
deepest depths and finds monster who's a
monster so terrible that the fish swim
away just at the sound of his voice just
like what's his name uh he who who you
shall not be named Voldemort
right you can't even say is damned name
same with monstro Pinocchio goes down
there goes into the whale what happens
Geppetto says there's no getting out of
this there's no getting out of this we
just have to sit here in cook fish and
Pinocchio thanks cook and then he starts
breaking up all the chairs and
everything and as far as freaking out
like what are you doing breaking all
these chairs what are we going to sit on
and then Fidel Q likes them on fire he's
a master of fire it's a shamanic ritual
but he is a master of fire that's what
human being is he gets everything
burning of course you bet it was all
freaked out about that because what are
they going to sit on and Pinocchio
thinks who cares about sitting we're
going to solve the problem once and for
all and so then the whale turns into a
fire-breathing dragon which is pretty
damn weird thing for a whale to do half
kills Pinocchio he washes up on shore
dead but he saves his father man at the
very end of the movie he's lying on his
bed all drown they're all like having a
show he's a dead puppet now it's like do
you want to be a live puppet or a dead
puppet
well maybe the dead puppet is better
than the live puppet it depends on where
you're going so then he's on the bad the
Blue Fairy comes down and says will you
be honest and courageous hey now you're
real you know and then they have a
little party that's that's just exactly
right none of that exactly right so
that's how that's part of the hero
mythology is the rescuing of the father
what is
to the bug because otherwise you're a
corpse like you're a historical creature
your cultural creature your you cannot
live without your culture you think you
can but you can it disappears them and
you don't even look I'll give you an
example in the Mesopotamian creation
myth which I'm going to tell you about
next week one of the things that happens
is that the first round of gods so
they're like primordial forces they're
pretty damn careless and they kill their
flawed and they make this place to live
on his corpse okay that's where we live
we live on the corpse of our ancestors
because we live in this society then
it's the product of dead people we've
got this dead element but we're living
on it okay they're very careless they
tell it thee so they delete render it
completely dead well what happens is
taya Matt who's the mother of chaos she
comes flooding back and she thinks oh
you killed the thing that protects you
you just wait to see what happens and
that's exactly it
you killed the thing that structures you
you won't know it
it's like Nietzsche's prediction from
the death of God it's like you killed
this you think oh it doesn't make any
difference it's like taught wrong it's
it's like the Striders protecting the
hobbits you get rid of that thing that
protects you and chaos comes flooding in
and you like you have no idea what's
possible we do though because we live
through the 20th century we know exactly
what's possible you know hundreds of
millions of unnecessary deaths
that's what's possible we're lucky we
didn't blow the whole damn thing up so
and we still could so people pursuing
their dead ideologies you don't rescue
the dead for that you're the puppet of
death that's what you are worried and
that cheery note